the Joe Rogan experience certainly Toro
gotta fight was brutal brutal yeah yeah
he's a monster I give him a lot of
respect I do you know I mean not a lot
of people do but they're crazy
the man's just being him well he talks a
lot of [ __ ] but you got to separate that
from what he does yeah I mean when you
watch him fight the guy is defensively
spectacular yeah he knows exactly when
he wants to Canela fight I've watched
eikenella fight at least three times and
when you watch him stand in front of
Canelo Canela throws a left he's right
he's over here pop take that jab with
you yeah and chanel is like just with
him yeah throwing punches you can see
that the look in his face like god damn
man I'm in here with a master yeah this
is a master boxer and I'm learning a
lesson here you know the good thing is
you know he learned that lesson the
right way and now look good yeah yeah
Canelo's a monster dude any monster
defensively you know you see some of his
defense now and even me like I look at
his head more like god damn you know
he's against Danny Jacobs just a little
while ago like his head movement is just
on point that was a great fight because
Danny Jacobs is a [ __ ] killer yeah
and I was pulling for Jacobs but I had
to I had to give it to Canelo I'm like
he really took what he learned from
Floyd and yeah you know sometimes you
need that you know that it's even like
how you said me at Georgia are kind of
similar mm-hmm I tried to pick a fight
with the man like like I wanted to fight
him just because going into I was like
hey win lose or draw I'm gonna learn
something from this month
boy he gonna know he was in a fight i'ma
show up i'ma give him everything I got
but I knew just for the future unlike
that would a fight like that is just
gonna propel you it's just gonna get
better you know you I think he's gonna
want to find could be probably I think
probably that's what I think I think if
Dustin Poirier if could be beats Dustin
Poirier khabib is gonna lobby for a
fight with George yeah that's a hard
thing and it's a fight to make beats
George I think he's gonna retire that's
what I think I think khabib only has a
few more fights left in them
I don't think he I don't think he
necessarily wants to fight for a long
time I think you're right he's
undefeated he smashes everybody yeah you
know and I think he'll go down as one of
the greatest it ever did it if he beats
George if he beats Georgie's George in
there I mean if he could even get George
in there I mean who the [ __ ] knows how
that if that could ever play out yeah I
mean I want that date one of but we'll
see how that whole thing it also for the
USC it wouldn't be for a title which is
a problem apparently with when they when
they have a problem with like cell and
pay-per-views one of the big problems is
and this is why look everybody else why
do they have any room tiles the reason
why they have interim titles cuz people
see that title and they [ __ ] they
click that pay-per-view when they might
not that's real it makes it's a big
factor in any place into the yo-yo your
mindset as a fighter too yeah and so
George would have to come back
I mean someone with 160 or they go to
165 you know you know just saying like
eNOS said on the way to do this is did
that doesn't mean that much because Dan
has also said that women would never
fight in the UFC but Dana said on record
there won't be a 165 while he's working
there we hear oh I hear oh I don't like
that thinking I hear them though but you
know I don't have more weight classes
yeah I don't get it you can make the
khabib and George fight and it'd be
nothing
every time and George wants that fight
too you know even just to say hi I mean
you cool [ __ ] but George even
more so I tried to pick a fight with of
it like you know for real and he called
me and we talked for like over an hour
he's like explain it to me is like they
say I listen I cannot fight you right
now gymnastic I can't do the exit listen
I can only do it if I talked to him
recently if I haven't talked to him
recently it goes away I forget it but
it's a musically is a great fighter but
he wanted I am a better fighter than him
and I feel it I feel it there's risk of
a war you know what I mean sure I'm the
type I just like taking a big risk you
know more than anything but George is
where you hope you are ten years from
now
George is 36
years old sure right he's 36 or 37 he
said he's in that range 36 37 years old
you know he did it all yet it all know
he's now he's in the position where he's
just trying to get them fired oh [ __ ]
yeah see how much time ya know and and
even when he was explaining to me like I
was like Mack I really can't hate you
for this like you you know you kept it
like as straightest yes please like you
know it's just too much wrist and you
know it's like for what sorry like I get
it bro make your money look I go hey you
know hey you know I tried steel and and
I think he got it - he was like you know
I get with he's a brilliant guy when you
this see and talk to him and just the
way he breaks down life - what he's
thinking about life he's thinking about
it very smart very smart that's why when
he won the time I was like yeah I'm good
I feel like you take it take that title
I beat Michael Bisping and I'm gonna
just ride off in the sunset here for a
little bit and hold in a holding pattern
I'm waiting for the next big one to come
around the next big challenge